But Deutsche Bank isn't.
Donald Trump's only problem right now.
He has another problem in the form of Republican
Congressman Justin Amash.
Several days ago, Justin Amash and republican
congressman from the State of Michigan took
to Twitter to explain that after reading the
molar report, and that's important, he came
to the conclusion that Donald Trump did in
fact committed impeachable offenses and that
Attorney General William Barr did in fact
mislead everyone in this country about what
was actually in the Mueller report.
Well, obviously Donald Trump was not too happy
about a fellow Republican saying that this
guy could be impeached for what he's done,
and Trump lashed out on Twitter with the following
series of tweets here.
He said, never a fan of at Justin Amash, a
total lightweight who opposes me in some of
our great republican ideas and policies just
for the sake of getting his name out there
through controversy.
If he had actually read the biased Mueller
report composed by 18 angry dems who hated
Trump, he would see that it was nevertheless
strong on no collusion and ultimately no obstruction.
Anyway.
How do you obstruct when there is no crime
and in fact the crimes were committed by the
other side.
Justin is a loser who sadly plays right into
our opponent's hands.
I didn't know it was even possible to squeeze
in that much misinformation and know that
many lies into a shingle tweet, but the president
somehow managed to do it first and foremost.
His claims of no collusion.
The reports specifically comes to the conclusion
that because of all the lies told to Robert
Mueller and the investigators by the Trump
administration and by the Trump campaign,
they weren't able to continue chasing leads.
They'd been lied to so much that they could
not reach a definitive conclusion on collusion.
As for the obstruction, they lay that out
pretty clearly.
There was obstruction.
Muller just didn't want to be the one to indict
the president because he was still working
off that outdated and completely false DOJ
memo from decades ago that says, you can indict
a sitting president.
You actually can.
Legal scholars agree you 100% can.
There's nothing wrong with it.
There's no precedent to say you can't.
Mueller just wanted to say, okay, that that's
up to you.
You go ahead and do this Justice Department
and then William Barr obviously comes out
with his little four page cliff's notes version
of this and says, nope, everything's cool.
We're good to go.
We're not going to press charges.
Let's all move on.
Which is exactly what William Barb was hired
to do.
Justin Amash did, unlike Trump claimed read
the report and what's really interesting to
me is that in his series of tweets where you
spelled this out, there was one thing that
stuck out to me the most and he said that
it was the pattern of behavior.
Yeah.
The Muller report established a pattern of
behavior of criminal activity by Donald Trump.
Now, any good prosecutor in this country understands
that when you're prosecuting somebody, the
first thing you want to establish is a pattern
of behavior.
To say that this is how this person has lived
their life.
They broke the law here.
They did it here.
They did it here, they did it here, and they're
doing it now and that's why they're in court.
If you can establish that pattern, it's much
easier to get a conviction
and Republican representative Amash here says
that the pattern exists.
Mueller laid out that pattern for us.
We know it's real.
We know it happened.
The big problem here is that obviously this
doesn't change anything.
Just because we have one republican joining
the impeachment train doesn't suddenly mean
we're going full steam ahead.
Nancy Pelosi, you know, speaker of the House
of Representatives has made it clear that's
not the past.
She wants to go right now, so we're stuck.
It also doesn't mean there's going to be an
avalanche of more Republicans saying, yes,
that's a great idea.
Let's impeach.
That ain't going to happen and even if it
does happen, it's only going to happen in
the House of Representatives where we could
already impeached without a single republican
vote, but you're not going to get the ones
in the Senate.
I applaud congressman, a mosh
for putting country over party.
Unfortunately, there's not enough to public
is willing to do that.
I'm Farron cousins
with
the David Pakman,